you know Findlay Subaru of Las Vegas the
sponsors of this segment is all about
that love promise keeping them at the
heart of our community
[Music]
it's February so love is in the air but
that's a year-round thing here at
Findlay Subaru right Burton yes it is
love makes the world go round and it's
what makes a Subaru a Subaru absolutely
now what does love mean to you guys here
I think that you can best describe it
with the acronym heart it starts with
honesty knowing that we can always
you're always going to hear the truth
you're always going to know that we're
gonna tell you up front everything going
on and it is what it is you know and so
that's where it starts and then empathy
you know a lot of times we don't
consider where somebody's coming from
maybe they've had a hard day maybe
they've just wrecked their car maybe
they can't afford the service that
they're having to do to their car we
always want to embrace that empathy and
and see what we can do to make a
difference and then it goes on to
appreciation you know to make somebody
feel valued to appreciate them how can
we do that and that's that's something
we're always looking for new ways to do
and then respect R is respect and and we
respect people's time we respect what
what their needs are and how can we meet
those needs and then finally we earn the
trust that the team is is trust the love
promise is something you guys do year
round as well and I heard it was
recognized nationally yeah you know it
was really cool you know the the pillars
of the love promise or Subaru loves the
Earth Subaru loves pets super loves to
give or or to to help and Subaru loves
learning with that Subaru loves learning
we went to Mary MB Earl Elementary
School this last fall and I got to read
to
um a whole group of students we we
donated over 500 books to the kids they
all got to take a book home and then we
were able to donate 12 500 to the school
to be used for the students in the
classrooms and just the supplies that
normally teachers have to have to you
know take the money out of their pockets
and so that earned a kind of a national
recognition for us what's your latest
effort to share the love well because
Valentine's Day is this month we're
doing 14 days of love with Helping Hands
in Nevada and and just this morning we
were out and uh going to a seniors home
and seeing what we can do to help with a
refrigerator that wasn't working
properly and and repairs in the homes
well it's great to give to the
organizations but when you can go into
somebody's home take them some flowers
take them some balloons say will you be
my Valentine and then fix the
refrigerator it's great now here at
Subaru where you guys keep people
feeling loved but also safe with your
car so what's new in the inventory
what's on the showroom floor well we
actually have cars on the showroom floor
which is a celebration in and over right
now we have inventory I just saw today
as I drove in that there was a whole
truckload of cars coming awesome so
really inventory volume uh is picking up
and good chance if you come in today and
you're looking for any Subaru model
you're gonna find it here but we have
great financing too even though the
rates are climbing we still have rates
as low as 3.9 percent up to 48 months on
approved credit on select models so you
know it's it's it's just a great time to
buy a great time to buy and a great time
to spread love as always so let's end it
with that acronym because I love this
heart it is great honesty empathy
appreciation respect and interest thank
you Burton
write that down okay thank you Finley
Subaru of Las Vegas for sponsoring this
segment call
702-495-2100 or just visit Subaru of Las
vegas.com for more information and don't
forget that special offer rates as low
as 3.9 percent financing for up to 48
months for well-qualified buyers
all right Kindle